normally when you come out and speak
about herbalife the stock goes up since
you spoke over the summer it has been
steadily going down maybe it's a risk
that you're coming and talking now
what's going on so we've actually come
up with some new stuff living out on
Herbalife we always have something new
we always learn something new and what's
changed there's a lot of the former
Herbalife employees Toph distributors
are going state's evidence and they're
also coming to Pershing Square so we got
a very interesting video that was filmed
by Herbalife a table by Herbalife film
by Herbalife about October of 2005 you'd
say oh that's nine years ago but you
know wait to see the video and it's a
video of one of the top Herbalife
distributors I think he's in the top ten
talking to other top distributors a
member of the board of directors several
senior executives the company who were
senior vice presidents who are now
senior vice presidents of Herbalife and
he's talking about how Herbalife is
basically a pyramid scheme